welcome to the anti-aging seminar today
we're going to answer a question is it
possible to reverse the aging process or
at least slow it down I believe it is so
before we get into how to do that I want
to talk about a big problem in health
care we're running into right now and
that has to do with there is no
prevention it's all treating symptoms
it's not preventing anything so let me
just show you something right here this
is a book called franc net or MD
endocrinology and we're going to talk
about the adrenal gland because there's
an aging horror mountainous called
cortisol and cortisol will make you
older and so you need to know about it
you need to know how to undo it and slow
it down and this is what it says the
normal adrenal gland has an enormous
functional reserve indeed the adrenal
deficiency does not become clinically
manifest until 9/10 of the adrenal has
been rendered unresponsive now what does
that mean that means that before it
shows up in a blood test it has to be
90% destroyed you see the problem if you
wait for your adrenals to be showing up
on a blood test it's too late and the
same thing goes with the heart does
anyone know the first symptom of a heart
attack over 50% the time well guess what
it is it's actually there is no symptom
its death you just die so sometimes your
body gives Clues some your times your
body does not give Clues you really
can't go by symptoms same thing with the
liver your liver has to be almost
completely destroyed before it shows up
in a blood test so what we're going to
get in today is some of the problems
some of the solutions in relationship to
the anti-aging cycle all right there's
two situations you have right here you
have creating health okay
versus treating disease so the medical
model is this will be here treating
disease and that's that basically what
they do I want to set up a new model and
that's called creating health and
avoiding disease it's completely
different what we want to do is we want
to stay over here and how do we create
health well through your food
the nutrients in your foods the type of
exercise the sleep the things you're
doing to reduce stress all these things
are creating health and of course the
counter creating of the health is just
the opposite
you know it's what you're putting in
your food as far as junk foods bad foods
artificial things alcohol not sleeping
stressing your body out all those things
are counter creating your health but
there's also something else and that has
to do with doing nothing all right
doing nothing is counter creating your
health because if you do nothing it's
your body's gonna fall apart
so if you sit in the couch all day
you're not going to create any health or
you're going to counter create your
health so here's the thing here's the
problem with treating the disease model
what happens is that the doctor says you
have to wait you have to wait six months
and we're going to test you again so
every six months we're going to test you
we're going to test you until you have
this disease well by the time you wait
you're already going to have it so my
suggestion is that we actively and
aggressively create your health now
because the odds are against you do you
realize that cancer takes 20 years to
grow in your body before even shows up
on a test twenty years that's two
decades so you really can't wait and
then because when you wait and then you
actually are diagnosed it takes
incredible energy to undo this thing in
fact when you get chemotherapy
the success rate after five years
there's only 2% so the disease model
treating the disease model doesn't work
it's very very expensive and the
prognosis is not very good and there's a
lot of side effects because the drugs
create other complications what I
suggest is we do this we really focus on
this creating health thing because this
is all if you want to know about
anti-aging it's right here it's all
about creating your health it's about
creating your cells healthier it's like
building this thing up that will make
you younger I'm doing it personally in
about three years I'll be 50 I feel like
I'm 20 but when I was in my 20s I felt
like I was 90 so I've been actively
building up my health and creating my
health and I will tell you that this
model really works so my goal with you
is to make you more
we're of this right here put your
attention on this okay because every
single day whether you know it or not
you either creating your health or your
counter creating your health which is
basically creating disease so there are
little actions that you can do each day
that make a huge difference but there's
really two mistakes that people make
number one is waiting until they have a
problem and men are too notorious for
this because they tend to be more macho
or they wait and they don't want to
admit that they have weaknesses and I
treat small percentage of men but only
because their wife dragged them to my
office and then they decided okay I'm
ready to do something about it but women
tend to be more responsible
hopefully you men in the audience are
going to be more responsible today but
what we want to do is we want to not
wait anymore we want to take action
waiting never works because sooner or
later you are going to have a health
problem I know some of you have parents
or grandparents in your family right now
that just out of the blue got sick and
now all the family is sucked into trying
to help this person so waiting always
leads to more problems down down the
road so that's that's mistake number one
mistake number two is that you have no
health goal or your goal is too small
it's like what does your health go well
I don't know I'm just going to wait til
see what happens to my life in a couple
years my goal for my body is to get
younger every year that I get older does
that sound like a good idea yeah
absolutely because if you do that if you
actively create on your health then
guess what happens to this disease State
you avoid it in fact when it's like
learning karate then no one wants to
fight you you're actively countering and
bulletproofing your health for the
future and so that way you take yourself
out of the risk factors and out of the
state where your doctor saying hey let's
wait in six months and let's test you
and see when you have it so then we can
treat with the drug
I want to aggressively actively promote
and create a health reserve that you are
totally bulletproof for the future now
let's talk about the three mistakes that
people make repetitively over and over
and over without really knowing they're
making mistake the first mistake is
these things called antioxidants and I
know some of you are taking
them vitamin E and vitamin C and and I
guess the Chinese herb tea that you're
drinking and the ginkgo biloba and all
that stuff well let me explain something
the whole free radical theory is a myth
now before you reject that because I was
the guy that was pushing that at one
time thinking that there's these free
radicals going around destroying her
body making it ourselves older until I
started to go and read some of the
studies that were done on these
antioxidants so let me read you a couple
these are scientific studies that will
show you that these the antioxidants
either don't work or they make you worse
check this out
here's one the alpha tocopheryl it's
vitamin E beta carotene it's vitamin A
prevention study this was done in 29,000
people okay it increases taking
antioxidants increase the risk of
cardiac death stroke and risk for
coronary events okay that the trial was
stopped early all right the next one
called the polyp prevention study done
in 751 people neither beta carotene or
vitamin C or vitamin E reduce the
incident of tumors or polyps or
prevented any polyps okay and then we
have another study the physician study
this says that showed no difference in
the incident of malignant cancer stroke
or cardiovascular disease or overall
mortality in 12 years of taking the
supplement here's another one so there's
no significant difference in major
coronary events but significantly more
deaths from fatal coronary heart disease
is this mind-blowing or what the actual
solutions that people are trying to take
the actual vitamins that people are take
are actually making them worse now how
can that be let me explain something in
nature all vitamins come in complexes
okay a complex is a series of complex
parts that make up a whole now let's
just take the vitamin C complex here we
have one part called the ascorbic acid
that's the anti oxidant portion of the
vitamin C complex and it also has some
cofactors here vitamin J vitamin P that
the bioflavonoids that you probably have
heard about and then you have copper
that's some mineral and then you have
vitamin K so this is what makes up the
vitamin C complex well when you're
taking these antioxidants and all those
studies most of the studies were doing
and we were doing on on synthetic
vitamins and synthetic antioxidants they
weren't using natural antioxidants so
anytime you take a vitamin fraction or a
part of vitamin out of the normal
complex you create deficiencies in the
other factors I had a patient go to
Mexico he had cancer and they injected
him with over a hundred thousand
milligrams of synthetic ascorbic acid
which is vitamin C and this guy came
back with the worst vitamin C deficiency
that you ever seen in your life
he had bleeding gums he had spider veins
in his nose he looked like he had scurvy
which is a vitamin C because he was very
tired and he had varicose veins and
hemorrhoids which are all vitamin C
deficiencies the very thing that you're
taking in high dosages but synthetic are
creating the deficiency and you know
many people are doing that they buy
cheap vitamins that are believe it or
not made from petroleum products they're
not natural they're not from plants but
they can they sit and some people say
there's no difference well let me ask
you this is there a difference between
artificial flavoring and real flavoring
I mean I think there is I believe
there's a big difference between
synthetic and natural so anytime you
take artificial synthetic fraction
native vitamins from the complex and
take those in mega dosages you're gonna
be creating problems and I can prove it
because right in the studies all those
were done synthetically mistake number
two taking hormones all right now I know
there's a lot of people are doing the
bioidentical hormones and doing
synthetic hormones and let me just
explain some challenges but before I do
that I just have to explain what a
hormone is because it can be very
complex first of all that you have to
know there's six hundred hormones in
your body and when you add a hormone
into the mix you create a lot of
confusion but what happens is that
hormones are communications that are
sent from one part of the
to another and they travel through the
blood so these are hormones and what
makes a hormone are things called glands
and it usually goes to some other part
of the tissue like let's say this is the
ovary and this is the pituitary so you
always have these glands that are
sending receiving and then returning
communications just like you would talk
to someone you know you talk to someone
they spoke supposedly there should be
listening to you and they should be
acknowledging here when you talk to them
you're not going to talk to someone
they're just sitting there not
acknowledging you same thing with the
body so anytime you have too much of a
hormone you have a certain problem
anything not enough you have a
completely other set of problems so
here's the problem when you take
hormones you actually shut down the
gland you make the gland not have to
produce you make the body now dependent
on that hormone same goes with thyroid
any hormones in the body that's why I'm
not crazy about taking hormones unless
you've tried everything here's what's
really missing no one is looking at the
glands repairing the glands healing the
glands this is the secret to anti-aging
because you have to be able to know what
to do to heal the glands now one of the
biggest things that destroys your glands
are a thing called endocrine disruptors
what is an endocrine disruptor an
endocrine disruptor is anything in the
environment that can destroy or
interfere or mimic other hormones and
specifically it mimics estrogen and you
know that estrogen has a tendency to
cause cancer and trigger cancer it can
create a lots of problems for you too so
even some of the anti breast cancer
drugs are things that block estrogen in
the body so endocrine disruptors are any
chemical like pesticide insecticides
herbicides fungicides heavy metal
country-and-western
I'm just saying if you're awake all
these things in the environment that are
messing up your hormones golf course
they pesticides the office everywhere so
what happens what you have to do is you
have to
aware of that number one and you have to
be able to detoxify your body from the
endocrine disrupters it just so happens
there is a wonderful set of foods that
you can eat right now that can dismantle
these chemicals from your liver without
creating any detox reactions now would
you like to know about that would anyone
like to know about that okay you would
like to know about that and they're
called cruciferous okay cruciferous are
those vegetables like broccoli Brussels
sprouts cabbage kale and these
vegetables that not very many people are
eating have the ability to reach out
from your liver in pull these chemicals
dismantle them and deactivate them why
because these things cause cancer they
create disease thank goodness that we
have our own food supply we have things
that can protect our bodies my favorite
food is kale why because kale has the
most nutrition of any plant on the
planet it's the healthiest food that you
could possibly get does it taste good
well that's a different topic but it's
good for you it's a little bitter but
you can mix it with different things
kale is my favorite because it can has
anti-cancer properties it can make your
cells young again it can pull these
chemicals out so to salvage the gland we
need to be consuming cruciferous and you
know what's really cool about that only
three cups of cruciferous every single
week will decrease certain cancer rates
by 48 percent okay just remember that
because these phytonutrients have
special properties that if eaten in
their complex not synthetically can
create massive amounts of anti-aging
properties okay so let's let's let's
look at something happen as you age
every single year you age your hormones
are declining that's the good news I
mean that's the bad news
so let's look at this this is an aging
over time there's hormones that are
decreasing with time and there are
hormones that are increasing with time
all right
the ones that increase with time
are the aging hormones specifically
cortisol that's the bad hormone that's
the one that causes belly fat that's the
one that destroys your collagen in your
skin and your joints and your arteries
that can set you up for strokes okay
that's the one that makes you old inside
and out it keeps you from sleeping it it
gets it causes it sets up a situation we
can get autoimmune diseases I mean think
about what cortisol is if they inject
you with it it's an anti-inflammatory so
that means that all the inflammatory
diseases are adrenal why don't they fix
the gland that's a good question
so cortisol that goes up as you age and
let's say this is 50 years old right
here okay 50 years old and then we have
this other one going down is called
growth hormone okay now growth hormone
is not just about growing it's about
making you young growth hormone is the
main anti-aging hormone it occurs when
you're sleeping so if you're not
sleeping it's not working
well the other thing that triggers it is
exercise but not any old exercise so no
I'll get to that in a moment but this is
a very very important thing that
decreases and that's why it's so hard to
lose weight as you age because this is
the main hormone that burns fat
especially in your belly okay so what we
want to do with the anti-aging strategy
is work we need to get the glands
healthy and we need to get cortisol down
to zero and get growth hormone as high
as we can all right so that's what we're
talking about so so what we want to do
we want to understand what gland or what
organ does growth hormone work through
litter what destroys the liver is
alcohol even wine beer mad dog 20/20 and
also a lot of cooked proteins a lot of
cook protein powders the soy powder is
very bad for the liver soy protein
isolate powder is very bad for the liver
when you actually have these powders at
your house that you're taking look at
the ingredients make sure it doesn't
have this soy because it's very bad and
liver in fact they found it increases
tumors in your liver
so we have the thing that the liver
loves is bitter vegetables and there we
got the cruciferous again we keep coming
back to those darn cruciferous
vegetables
now the only thing green that I ate
growing up was pistachio ice cream and
lime green jello I never ate any
vegetables until I got out of college
and that's why I hit bottom I was very
very old on the inside and going down
real rapidly I hit bottom when I was 28
but I decided at that point that I'm
done I'm ready to get my body in the
best shape that I've ever been because I
if I didn't I would end up in serious
shape so I've I've been consuming a lot
of cruciferous my favorite is kale for
probably about 15 years why because I
found that was the food that heals the
liver and so that's why I want you to
eat that as well or eat similar types of
food so that the liver needs bitter
vegetables to heal itself okay so now
let me show you something a strategy
that I use to help people get younger is
increase this growth hormone and by the
way you can buy it you can buy it from
Adam you can actually have your doctor
ordered for you
it will regenerate your organs within
three months it will lose a lot of
weight you get lean body mass it costs
$12,000 though but it caused diabetes as
a side effect about 3 to 4 months later
so remember I talked about when you take
a hormone it activates your gland that
makes it so there's another way to
increase growth home and by 450 percent
does anyone want to know what to do how
to do that anyone I don't think you guys
are really ready for this maybe I'll
show you at the next seminar the
advanced seminar you want to know ok
fine I'll tell you so to increase the
growth from about 450 percent what we
want to do is we want to do a type of
exercise that is called interval
training that would be the short little
workouts with lots of rest back and
forth you can do a little hopping on
stairs you can do bike riding you can do
little jogging things you can do jump
rope whatever it doesn't matter but the
key is the interval short rest
short rest as compared to jogging doing
marathons okay you will not increase the
growth hormone so the type of exercise
but they found that increases of this
interval training alright but here's the
problem with some of you you you're not
ready to do interval training yet
because when you exercise you stress
your body out and then you stop
what's supposed to happen you're
supposed to then recover and get healthy
and burn fat right here in the recovery
after the workout 14 hours later but
most of you your recovery is so bad and
I'm talking about your body's ability to
rejuvenate you're not ready for the
interval training because it's more of a
stress see here's the thing
it's not about the quantity of exercise
it's about how your body can recover
from that exercise I wrestled in college
I was undefeated for the first week and
then I was the worst guy on the team
because I would work out twice thinking
more is better the point is it's not
it's about your ability to bounce back
from things there is something in your
body that is actively getting you to
recover from stress actively it's an
active machine I'm not going to give you
the long name for it but there's
something that helps you to recover so
let's just say you run up a stairs okay
and you get to the top how fast is your
pulse rate come back to a normal range
well guess what gets your pulse rate
back to that normal range this specific
system so it's called a recovery system
and you also have something that reacts
to the stress to get your pulse rate to
adapt to the climbing of the stairs - so
in any given moment
you're constantly reacting to stress and
adapting the stress reacting and
adapting to stress so this brings up the
next most important thing and that is
the aging hormone called cortisol what
destroys your body is stress how many of
ever experienced stress at least once
before got one person and I'm being
sarcastic all of you it's okay to
experience stress as long as you can
recover from it so here's another secret
if you experience stress make sure you
actually do things to extract the stress
as you
go through stress because unfortunately
we can't move you all to an island right
now in the beach for about the next six
months so you can rejuvenate so you're
gonna have to do things to undo the
stress what I do for my body is I teach
people how to do acupressure it's a
non-invasive way of extracting stress
because that way each night you can pull
the stress out because here's the thing
all stress is accumulative your bodies
are like buckets and you're filling up
with stress every day and if you don't
get rid of it that sustained stress will
burn you out a lot of you mothers in the
audience are experiencing that you put
your body on the back burner until one
day when you get after menopause you're
like what the heck happened to my body
because you've been pushing putting
yourself on the back burner like I said
it's okay to experience stress as long
as you can recover from it and you can
keep going so sleep is vital extracting
stress doing things to decrease stress
is vital because stress is the number
one killer out there right now and a lot
of you are going through lots of massive
stress so I want you to do things every
single day that actively get rid of your
stress or reduce your stress why because
you can't escape stress but you can do
something about it you can you can
actually handle your physical a body's
ability to adapt from the stress so like
I said before there's a program that I
put people on that actually help them
recover but sometimes that's confusing
the people they want like what do you
mean recover what I mean bounce back how
do you know you have low recovery well
how was your tolerance of stress do
people get on your nerves
do you have a low tolerance to
incompetent people you get on edge do
you have you get overwhelmed that means
you lost your ability to recover okay
when the more you lose your ability to
recover the less exercise is going to
help you lose weight especially in the
midsection why because that's when all
the fats burned all right so this
recovery thing is everything and to
build up your recovery in yourself get
them to adapt better is then probably
even more important than anything so you
want to adjust your exercise to your
to recover okay so we have two things
going on we have the reaction the stress
and the recovery from stress and we want
to be able to react to it but we have to
adapt to it as well and this is one of
the most important things so let's say
you're stressed right now and you don't
know what to do and you you're probably
maybe me or you're overtraining well
just do walking right now and build up
to it over a period of time but the key
is never to over train because again if
we can get you to recover better we can
increase growth hormone and we can then
make you younger as you get older
mistake number three not isolating and
being aware of and getting healthy your
weakest link all of you are gonna die of
something someday the key is knowing
what you're gonna die of is it going to
be the heart is it going to be cancer is
it going to be the pancreas is it going
to be the liver is it gonna be an artery
what is it gonna be you're as strong as
your weakest link and what you want to
do is you want to identify what weak
links you have and put a lot of
attention on creating health in that
area it's so simple but people don't
look at it like that now you how do you
know you wake us link look at your
parents do they have diabetes I know
some of you are on medication right now
well that will be a weak link right
there to start with I mean if you want
if you're confused with what weak link
you have you can get help from me or you
can just start with the heart because
most people die of a heart attack
some of the common things that destroy
the heart are vitamin B deficiency
coming from eating too many refined
grains like breads pasta cereal crackers
biscuits waffles pancakes muffins things
like that and sugar that will destroy
the heart faster than anything also
depletes you a vitamin E which then will
cause a different type of heart problem
which is like heart attacks angina
that's why vitamin E is good for the
heart if it's done naturally but how do
you become deficient vitamin E by
consuming too many of those refined
grains breads pastas or crackers
biscuits you know everyone's doing it so
we want to avoid those to protect your
heart we already talked about the liver
it doesn't like
a lot of cook protein doesn't like soy
powder it does like cook fats it likes
raw bitter vegetables okay what about
the pancreas
well it doesn't like sugar it doesn't
like hidden sugars like juice and like
the hidden sugars as msg and some of the
Chinese restaurants in the fast food
places all right so all these things are
very very vital when you're talking
about healing the body in getting
younger you don't want to take a global
approach you want to take a specific
approach and take one organ at a time
take your weakest like and bring it on
up some of you are so stressed out your
adrenal glands need to be rejuvenated
that would be a good place to start
because if you take that weak link and
you bring that thing up guess what you
did you allow the anti aging hormones to
work on your body just by automatically
bringing that down cortisol down and
that cortisol is at the heart of so many
illnesses from degenerative disease to
autoimmune to cancer to burning out the
heart so that would be a very vital goal